welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were going back to a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
everything we know so far about the
second season of the mandalorian the
Disney Plus show is now in production
and slowly the team behind it have been
dropping tidbits of information that
tease everything from its plot to the
show's release date and more obviously
there'll be heavy spoilers here itself
you haven't had a chance to watch the
first season and highly recommend that
you turn off now also if you like the
cover art of the thumbnail make sure you
check out slime house TV for toy reviews
movie news and actor interviews I'll
leave a link to their channel in the
description below and without the way
let's get into our breakdown of the
Mandalorians season 2
okay so the mandalorian season one or as
we called it Star Wars a solo dad story
centered around the titular character
who had been tasked with tracking down a
rare and dangerous bounty this was
revealed to be a force sensitive child
named baby Oda who the Empire were
looking to experiment on and clone
though mondo or as we later learned den
Joran initially did look like he was
going to complete the job he had a huge
change of heart and he who would blame
him just look at baby aura this made him
decide to protect the child much in the
same way that the Mandalorians protected
him in his youth and it put him into
conflict with the empire this came in
the form of Mothe Gideon who personally
tried to kill a character and take baby
otter back himself mando defeated them
off but he survived and the show ended
with the character brandishing the dark
saber a ceremonial Mandalorian
lightsaber that somehow the character
had managed to get hold of it was a huge
cliffhanger that opened up a hell of a
lot of questions and fans are expecting
great things from the show when it
returns but when exactly can we expect
it back well the creative team behind
the show announced that the new season
would be coming in the fall of 2020 via
Twitter this is a super tight turnaround
especially because the show debuted on
the 12th of November 2019 it looks like
Disney will be following a similar model
to Netflix and releasing seasons our
annual intervals so we can likely expect
season two to drop around about the same
time when the mandalorian first came out
it actually dropped two episodes in the
first week in order to help launch
Disney Plus but it is unlikely that this
will follow the same release style and
we will likely just be getting releases
weekly due to the fact that Jon Favreau
has confirmed that the show will drop
fall 2020 and the annual turnaround it's
likely that the series will come out on
Friday the 13th of November which may be
unlucky for some but a guarantee Star
Wars fans will have a blast as for the
story itself it looks like we'll be
traveling to the furthest reaches of the
universe with mono and baby Oda to
discover where the latter actually comes
from George Lucas has never revealed the
identity of Yoda species or even the
planet that
come from when he held the keys to the
kingdom he wanted it all to be kept
under wraps
however the Star Wars creator and now no
longer owns Lucasfilm
and thus he doesn't really have much say
over whether it's revealed or not though
it was initially thought that Yoda may
be ilanic this was officially denied and
thus we don't really know much about the
character baby Oda is now Dean Joran's
foundling and as we learn from the armor
in Episode eight he has a duty to
reunite it with its own kind however
neither the armor mando or any character
in the season knew anything about baby
Oda
or where he came from so it is difficult
to determine exactly where in the galaxy
he needs to start looking personally I
believe that rather than looking for a
planet directly manda will investigate
the force itself and begin to learn the
ins and outs of it we do know that
pretty much all of the characters in the
show were left very confused whenever
baby Yoda demonstrated his powers this
will likely leave the titular character
on a journey to discover how baby Yoda
possesses these incredible abilities and
who knows this could even lead him to
look for Jedi throughout the galaxy that
survived order 66 the Umrah did reveal
that she had heard of sorceress called
jedi and this could tip mano in the
direction of them though as we know they
aren't exactly thriving at this point we
will also likely learn the name of baby
Oda and recently on Twitter it was
posted that Disney CEO Bob Iger knew the
name of the character though he isn't
telling anyone this sent social media
into an uproar with many many people
giving their guesses on what the
character could be called Tiger Wood
titi said he thinks it's Nigel but
personally I actually think his name is
Steven Jenkins jr. look it looks like a
Steven or Andy you know you know when
you hear the name Andy and you just
think of a guy down the pub like Andy's
down the pub that sort of thing never
mind I think he looks like an Andy but
let me know what you think he looks like
anyway it's likely that we will learn
the background of the character and it's
going to be great seeing the new
characters that Manor meets along the
way in order to discover exactly what's
going on
though the series will be introducing a
lot more new names we do know from a
recent report
by deadline that the upcoming season
will also feature a character from the
Skywalker saga fabs did post a picture
of a gomorian who many of you will
recognize is the same species as the
guards at Jabba's palace and though some
sources have said that this could be
what they're referring to
we highly doubt it we've kind of
crunched the numbers and actually
believe that in his quest to find a Jedi
man though might actually discover the
opposite in someone far far worse but
who could the character actually be well
recently Rey Park posted a picture of
himself on Instagram in full Darth Maul
makeup as we know from solo rumours of
the character's death were greatly
exaggerated
and it does look like he's back though
the character was apparently killed
later in the law we do know that he's
harder to kill in rumors of a gambit
movie starring Channing Tatum so it is
likely that he's going to be back with
the Mandalorian season 2 filming right
now it does make sense that the actor
would dress up to appear like this in
the show the character not only knows
the ins and outs of the force but he's
also being connected to the dark saber
which we saw them off wielding at the
end of season 1 so it is possible that
it could be tied with this he's also
very connected to the underworld and the
circles that mando moves in so there is
potential that he could pop up could he
still be leading the black son and could
we see a return of emilia clark as Han
Solo's long-lost love I hope so and both
characters definitely deserve to get a
comeback especially after the big
cliffhanger that solo left us on anyway
that's just my theory going off the
image and who knows he could have just
been dressing up like that for a kid's
birthday party anyway there's also
potential that the original character
could be someone like Han admiral ackbar
bosque or basically anyone who's either
looking to help the Mandalorian or hunt
him there's also a lot of theories that
the character is gonna be Bubba Fett
after the events of episode 5 many fans
online speculated that the boots we saw
at the end of the entry belonged to the
galaxy's most infamous bounty hunter
though the character was seen to be
falling directly into the mouth of the
Sarlacc in Return of the Jedi we do know
in the expanded universe that he did
survive the thousand years of agonizing
digestion
the fan theories are right and fat made
it out and we got a glimpse at him but I
actually have a different theory and
it's something that's been backed up by
the upcoming Funko pop releases for the
series now I am willing to admit the
Spurs sound effects are exactly the same
for the character fans even lined the
two up side-by-side and yet they are the
same however I still don't think that is
fet but it may be a very close relation
okay so if you've been keeping a close
eye out you may have noticed that in the
Funko release there's a character that
we haven't been introduced to not only
this is character possess similar boots
but they also have a cape that is very
akin to the one that we see at the end
of episode 5 if she is a bounty hunter
then it makes sense why she would be hot
on the heels of Phoenix and the
high-value target in the entry if it is
this character then the Spurs themselves
could be a little hint that this is in
fact a limb fell in case you don't know
Ellen Bell is the daughter of boba fett
in the expanded Legend series this was
originally posted by inverse and looking
at it knowing that this mysterious
bounty hunter could be in the show and
the sounds they made it makes a lot of
sense obviously comment below if you
agree with that and lastly we do know
that moth Gideon will be returning to
get revenge the fact that he has the
dark saber carries a lot of weight with
it and lets us know that he was
instrumental in the Mandalorian purge
the dark saber was created by the first
Mandalorian to join the Jedi Order and
has been passed down from generation to
generation throughout the Creed I've
already made a full video breaking down
Gideon and how he likely got the weapon
and will do whatever he can to wipe them
out he knows Manos name because he
helped her seize the planet personally
and on Navarro he pretty much sent the
group into extinction after the uprising
in Episode three he's gonna want to
complete the set and I can see him
tracking down the two no matter the time
cost or energy that it takes either way
I'm very hyped for the Mandalorian
season too and I think it's gonna be
another great entry for the Star Wars
universe now obviously I would love to
hear your thoughts on the show and if
you're excited for the upcoming season
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and if you
wanna know more stuff about the
mandalorian and check out our breakdown
a moth Gideon and the dark saber which
should be popping up right now make sure
you check out our full breakdown of all
the leaked Batman set photos as well
which will be linked at the end as we go
over every shot and point out the tiny
bits of detail that hint towards the
film's time setting plot and how it
potentially ties into Joker you want to
come chat to me after the video that
makes you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey I'll head over to my
discord server which you'd be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
that early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free adjoining we have
an awesome community so hopefully I see
over there very soon we'll also giving
away a free copy of Joker which is one
of our favorite movies of the last year
and all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning it's like the video
make sure you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts in the
mandalorian in the comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of January and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
prize so best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace